okay hello I'm so deep so deep common
I'd like thank you organizers for
inviting me I'll talk today about
learning distributions from samples and
the setting is a minimax risk
formulation okay so let me begin this is
joint work with Ilan outlets key the HP
chop with um the thief thesaurus okay so
in order here is the setting consider
the problem of learning probability
distributions and samples are drawn iid
from a fixed distribution on an alphabet
of size K so x1 through xn are drawn iid
and this distribution is a distribution
over finite alphabet k is k is known to
you keep in mind n is the number of
samples k is the size of the the
alphabet and the probability
distribution takes values in the K
simplex which I'll denote by by Delta K
okay so to formalize our problem we need
a loss function which is a numerical
penalty for estimating the true
distribution P by your guess q so this
is this is a number which measures how
bad it is to guess the true distribution
P by Q so throughout the stock p is
going to be the distribution which
generates the samples and q is going to
be our guess our guess is based on the
samples the distribution is unknown to
us okay the minimax risk formulation is
the following for every possible
probability distribution p and every
estimator q which is designed based on
the samples you incur an expected loss
the expectation is over the randomness
of the samples are drawn according to e
you maximize this expected loss over all
distributions in the simplex and find
the estimator that minimizes this
worst-case loss so this number RK n R
stands for risk k is the alphabet size
and n is the number of samples just
tells you that this is really the best
you can do if you choose this estimator
no matter what what is the underlying
true distribution you will not incur a
penalty more than RK n
the question is what is the minimax risk
and what is the optimal estimator but
give me a characterization of RK n and
and the best estimator and of course the
answer will depend on what is the true
true loss function being used so finding
the exact answers to these questions are
often difficult and in this talk we will
look at asymptotic behavior of of the
minimax risk as as the alphabet is held
fixed a number of samples grows large
okay here are some important measures of
loss functions that are used in practice
relative entropy or the cool back
library divergent scale divergence
important and compression and prediction
there is the chi squared distance notion
of loss important multiple
correspondence analysis this l1 distance
very important and classification and
machine learning and there is Helen good
distance I'm just giving you some
examples or all of these motions of
distance that I'm talking about here are
actually special cases of the F
divergence by chisa for any convex
function f where f of 1 is 0 you can
define a notion of distance between P
and Q given by this formula and all the
all the ones I just talked about so far
are actually special cases of left
divergence although there are the
notions of distances well ok here is the
outline of the talk i will give you two
stories related to these notions of
distance one the minimax risk for
relative entropy this is an old story so
it's more of a literature review and
then i'll give you some of our new
results on chi squared distance before
some other results as well on l1
distance and other distances but i will
not be talking about it today so this i
will talk about two stories the relative
entropy first and then the the chi
squared distance ok so relative entropy
let's look at this we want to find the
best estimator which minimizes the worst
case expected loss in the relative
entropy sense ok the first thing very
obvious thing you'll notice is that
empirical estimator is a terrible idea
because if if a symbol has a positive
probability of showing up but for some
reason with low chance it never showed
up in your samples you and you assign it
a zero probability you will incur an
infinite cost so you will not be using
the empirical estimate
and in fact any estimator you use must
satisfy Cromwell's rule that you should
not assign zero probability to any
symbol Cromwell was not a statistician
it was a military leader and he used
these words to the Church of Scotland
and in subjective probability one says
that if you assign zero probability to
an event you're not allowed to change
your mind by basing updates and so
that's what the rule means but in our
context we will not be assigning zero
probability because we don't want to
infer and incur an infinite cost ok so
what else what else could we do we heard
as a very famous estimator the Laplace
estimator this was Laplace his answer to
the sunrise problem the probability you
assigned to a symbol is proportional not
to the number of occurrences that would
be the empirical estimator but to the
number of occurrences plus one so
therefore if you see the Sun rising for
n days in a row and the Sun has not
risen 40 days then Laplace would assign
a probability to the Sun rising tomorrow
by this formula n plus 1 over n plus
this was Laplace's famous answer to the
sunrise problem more general family of
estimators is the ad beta estimator here
the probability you assigned to a symbol
is proportional to the number of
occurrences of the symbol plus some
constant beta which is positive and a
Laplace is a special case where beta is
equal to 1 okay here I tie in with the
previous talk there's some very good
news associated with this family of
estimators and that's the following this
is a related problem it's not the same
problem it's a different problem but
it's closely related we don't want to
minimize the expected loss at time n but
we want to minimize the running some of
the expected losses from time 0 through
n so each time you come up with some
estimate based on the samples you've
seen so far and the lawsuit you suffer
is the sum of the losses from time 0
through time and so this problem becomes
the minimax redundancy problem in
universal source coding that Stefan
talked about and for this problem it's
very well known very famous result that
add one half is asymptotically optimal
the ad beta estimator with beta equals
one-half it's been known for a long time
more than 30 years and the asymptotic
behavior of this quantity is known is
nailed down two constants by work by why
tech and Marcelo Weinberger and others
so this quantity is perhaps you might
think that this is a more complex
quantity than this one but it's mean
it's very well understood okay now what
does that mean for our quantity where we
want to minimize only the expected loss
at time n here that is bad news surfski
showed firstly that if you want to use
ad beta beta equals half is not the best
beta and furthermore there is a natural
lower bound on RK n is the alphabet size
n is the number of samples we are
looking at Los under relative entropy
distance is a natural lower bound k
minus 1 over 2n and the best possible ad
beta rule is off by a constant factor it
cannot achieve that that natural lower
bound and after a series of of papers on
this particular problem if this this was
completely solved by brace and soil the
asymptotic behavior so which of these
bonds is really the correct one was was
discovered only ten years ago Vegas and
soil if you're wondering it's indeed the
same same base from raised paradox in in
traffic flow the answer is the following
give my sorry yeah Tom sore is really
Tom sorry
wait a minute I hope I'm not wrong I
believe it is Thomas oil the world bound
is tight that's the answer lower bomb
the asymptotic behavior the first order
term is K minus 1 over 2n but of course
no add beta estimator would achieve this
that already Krajewski showed us that so
in fact the optimal estimator which
achieves the first order term is it was
described by brace and soil to be the
following it is a varying ad beta rule
so the probability you assigned to a
symbol is proportional to the number of
occurrences of that symbol plus a beta
that also depends on the number of
occurrences okay if you see a symbol I
times the probability assigned to it is
proportional to I plus beta I and beta
is given by this formula beta 0 is a
half beta 1 is 1 and all subsequent
betas are three quarters this is this is
an estimator which gets you this
behavior so it seems so somewhat strange
and I will remote later why this kind of
thing is happening when I talk about chi
squared distance so let me move to the
chi squared distance story here we want
to minimize this particular form of loss
the chi squared distance between P and Q
is given by this some the best choice of
Q here is P I itself in which case the
loss is 0 and in every other case it's
strictly positive you want to minimize
this again Cromwell's rule applies you
should never be saying Qi 0 no matter
what you see and because you would incur
an infinite cost with some probability
so you should not be using this
estimator and here is our main result
for the chi squared distance notion of
loss we have an honest emphatic upper
bound and a non a somatic lower bound on
the minimax risk so for every possible
size of the alphabet k and for every
number of samples n this is an upper
bound on the minimax risk and this is a
lower bound but still these bounds are
pretty sharp
for example if you fix k and make and
very large than these bounds tell you
that the first order term in the
behavior of the minimax risk is
precisely k minus 1 over n up to and in
fact k minus 1 is exactly the right
constant here and that the second order
term is at most logarithmic log n over n
square if I had more time I would have
liked to go into more details of of this
of this proof but I would be I would not
be going into the details today any
guesses for what is the estimator that
achieves this upper bound
so why yes sorry now now a very simple
estimator does and its Laplace estimator
so the add one rule achieves gives you a
performance that's at least K minus 1
over n plus 1 yeah I will come to that
question that's a good one so I have
chosen to skip the details of the proof
because there is something I mean not in
the proof of this result but there is
something strange going on here that
magic something I find really very weird
and very very surprising and I want to I
want to go into the details of what is
that thing that I find very strange here
okay to describe that thing to you I
want to fix the alphabet size to be
binary okay even with binary you should
we should be able to appreciate it so k
equals to half of its size is too so now
the probability distributions is
basically we parameterize by one number
P P is the probability that X takes the
value 1 1 minus P is the probability
that it takes the value and so the
expected loss under a laplace estimator
is this thing let's parse this
expression the thing in brackets here is
the chi-squared loss function the thing
in green is precisely the laplace
estimator if you see I occurrences of a
symbol one you assign it a probability
that's I plus 1 over n plus 2 and the
thing in red is the probability that you
will indeed see I occurrences of the
symbol one this is the Laplace this is
the expected loss under the laplace
estimator and it's a very simple
calculation to show that this is 1 over
n the upper bounded by 1 over N for
every single value of the parameter P
and that gives you really the upper
bound that I talked about it's a trivial
calculation but really the surprise and
the weirdness starts with this question
in the spirit of XKCD what if what if
you choose some other estimator they use
an ad beta estimator instead and that is
that is the question I want to ask so
instead of beta equals 1 you let's say
you started out with some other beta and
try
to prove the same thing what would have
happened so here is the loss now let's
look at this expression again the
estimate of probability of a symbol that
appears i times in the sequence is high
plus beta over n plus 2 beta because we
are using an ad beta road okay let's
recap there are two this so much things
going on n is the number of samples
we're drawing p is the one parameter
that characterizes the probability
distribution on n binary alphabet is the
probability that x equals 1 and beta is
basically the ad beta estimator okay if
I see a symbol occurring I times I
assign it a probability that that's this
okay and this thing here is the expected
loss you see when you use the add beta
estimator let's give it a name I'll call
it f of P with n and beta as parameters
let's see a plot of this function i have
taken 10 samples I've drew 10 samples
and the x axis is the parameter P the y
axis is the expected loss at the
parameter P and I've chosen three
different values of beta 1 half 1 and 3
by 2 beta equals 1 is my mayest matter
Laplace estimator okay and it's good all
these losses are very small they're of
the order of 1 over N 0.1 now if i
increase n suppose I make n very large
what do you expect will happen to these
curves you are getting you're getting
more and more information about the true
parameter so we expect that the loss
should go down so let me take n equals
100 and see what happens so all these
curves are actually very are very close
to 0 that's nice and in fact you can
imagine these are all polynomials in p
this is a polynomial I have drawn for
you three polynomials of degree one on
102 okay but because we can't see them
properly here let me scale up the y-axis
to be able to see what's going on really
and here is the scaling the right
scaling is to look at 1 over N I draw a
black straight line and 1 over N because
that's where I expect the answer to be
right and then I there are these three
curves there's a green blue and red
green corresponds to beta equals
blue is beta equals one red is beta
equals 3 by 2 all right what do we see
here look at look at this curves in the
middle they are pretty much constant and
something strange is going on on both
the endpoints so to see what's going on
i'll focus as soo min to the endpoints
now so instead of looking at p from zero
through one i will make the x-axis also
scale of the scale have you have units
of 1 over n this is what it looks like
so just to summarize to two slides ago I
showed you what it looks like n equals
100 and then I'm just looking at this
corner using a microscope using a
magnifying glass this is what it looks
like both both dimensions are number of
order 1 over N and I see these curves
you see of these three curves the green
blue and red only one of them is always
below the straight line 1 over N and
that's the blue curve that's beta equals
one that's laplace estimator beta equals
half starts out below the curve but then
goes above and then starts coming down
somewhat strange and beta equals 3 by 2
is also starts out above the line so you
might think this is a this is a function
of n being 100 which is probably a small
number if n becomes very large maybe
this kind of thing will go away so let
me take the limit of this curve let me
keep zooming in and make an larger and
larger n goes to infinity this
phenomenon remains so at the boundary
for very tiny probabilities the expected
loss is above 1 over N no matter I
choose beta equals half or 3 by 2 and in
fact it turns out to be the case that if
I draw a curve for each beta only one of
these curves is always about that below
the line 1 over N so if i take the
maximum of the expected loss or the
entire range i will incur a loss that's
C of beta over N and C of beta strangely
is equal to 1 only for the Laplace
estimator for any other estimator you
are off by a fixed constant factor this
is the thing I wanted to to really talk
about and and what this says is
something there is a tremendous amount
of serendipity in world years in finding
that the laplacian estimator act
matched the natural lower bound and so
if I tell you two stories one for
relative entropy and one for chi squared
distance how many other divergence is or
how many notions of distance what do you
want to understand the minimax risk for
well for relative entropy I told you
this is optimal okay this
strange-looking thing is optimal now you
can imagine why because at the end point
strange things happen and you need to
use we need to perturb the estimator in
sharp ways so that it lies below what
you would you want for chi squared
distance something beautiful Laplace
estimator is asymptotically optimal add
one is add one works why is it why is it
so much simpler what is it in chi
squared distance is not there in
relative entropy then it becomes so much
simpler and the short answer to this
question which I also believe is
accurate is luck it's just it's
something I do not fully understand this
is the expected loss near the boundaries
of the simplex depends very erratically
on the loss function you choose the
relative entropy or chi squared distance
and on the specific estimator you choose
so there's some some strange thing
happening on the boundaries and if you
want to have a coherent understanding
for various various notions of loss for
example of family of F divergence loss
functions seems to me highly challenging
because of this specific thing happening
on the boundaries for example if you
look at Helen girl having your loss same
thing happens as in relative entropy the
best ad beta estimator cannot match the
performance of the natural lower bound
so you might have to look at strange
estimators like like this so if the
boundaries of the simplex are causing
these problems one thing you could do is
avoid the simplex boundaries and now
look at a very general notion of loss
let's look at F divergence loss and here
is our result suppose the probabilities
are bounded below by some constant alpha
ok all the pies are required to be
larger than some number alpha which is
positive
let f the f is going to define an F
divergence it has to be convex f of 1 is
0 what Ramon would call mild assumptions
f is trice differentiable and sub
exponential and truly they're mild I'll
come to why in this case the minimax
risk depends on Alpha of course without
the parameter that bounds all the
probabilities from below to differences
here the max is now over all these
probabilities that cannot be very close
to the simplex boundaries and the loss
is an arbitrary f divergence loss where
f is this function this has a very
simple formula in terms of the function
f it's k minus 1 times the second
derivative of f at 1 over 2n so this
unifies unifies all these existing
results under this under this constraint
yeah that's a very good question alpha
does not affect the first order term it
turns out and what is the estimator that
achieves this any ad better for any beta
positive is asymptotically optimal and
gets you this so if you want an
intuition for this result I look look
back at the picture I showed you there
are three different betas here all of
them between 0.2 and 0.8 have about the
same performance it's only the
boundaries that there are some erratic
behavior happening and why are these
assumptions mild well because you can
choose various other notions of lost
losses which are not not even F
divergences any smooth function which is
which is quadratic for PQ being closed
satisfies an essential result of this
form as long as you avoid the
probabilities that are very very close
to the boundaries of the simplex that's
really all I have I in summary I
described to you the minimax risk
minimax risk for a general loss function
i give you non asymptotic upper and
lower bounds for chi-squared notion of
loss and these bounds were quite sharp
in that they characterize the the first
order term in the asymptotic behavior
when the alphabet size K is held fixed
and the number of samples and grows I I
suggested that a general formula for a
wide family of loss functions such as an
arbitrary f divergence seems to be a
difficult prospect and that's because of
the erratic behavior at the at the
boundaries of the simplex so if you
avoid the boundaries then any add beta
estimator is optimal and there's a very
simple formula for the minimax risk in
terms of the loss function we have all
these results and sends some more on
other notions of distance l1 distance
and other distances coming up on archive
soon thank you very much so your
estimator is actually very lonely some
would you ask you ate it and this is
quite well understood you can get any
other perfect movie for 6p your problem
is that you want you nicole mustn't
projects for all p today from us about
to [ __ ] and he still knows how to do
actually for uniform a society for all
here i said you have to talk to them
because we're to dealing with this right
now so you know the Robbie knows result
of any of their versions can be
expressed as an integral stuff a civil
matter have you actually looked at just
what happens with the base best
divergence no I I have not perhaps you
can understand base risk even even
including this erratic behavior but our
our loss for made some assumptions here
that f should be smooth and so on so the
points of any of the bridges can be
expressed as an integral
so places but we don't expect this
behavior to be for example 1 over N
because even for the total variation
distance we have a 1 over square measure
the average is the prior brand yeah that
should be smooth or isn't right yeah
Thank You Chucky relation between this a
minus 1 over n factor and throughout
your results and also in the context of
grill of entropy and the same K minus 1
over to factor that appear ISM minimax
redundancy yeah that's a very good
question there are two notions the
minimax risk and the minimax redundancy
are related k minus 1 shows up because
it's the dimension of the simplex number
of free parameters and this number gives
you if you can characterize this number
it gives you an upper bound on the
minimax redundancy and brace and soil
showed that the upper bound is nearly
tight because this behaves like k minus
1 over 2n and when you add this up our
end you get K minus 1 or 2 log in but it
need not have been tight it happens to
be the case that in fact the you get
exactly the right constant also gentle
for this country thought you are taking
a goalie infinity McKay is fixed so
here's a little hole term I have tries
what's the hidden tape in a little altar
but not only had so this will further
Malik and K coaching to get together
what's up in 30 what's a great second
thing actually recently we have improved
the resulting process or and the result
the earth Queen roughly similar TSU TV
with steel back and wraps that look at
asleep beta so you get this little bit
jump but actually we characterize
analogy in public documents get very
high upper lower dance and which
improves relax it's a that's a good
comment yeah there is some dependence
here on K as well as alpha and if you
make gain an end both scale in some way
then I do not anticipate that a simple
formula like this might be available but
for chi-square divergence we have non
asymptotic bounds and they give you the
correct scaling even when K and grow
together thank you know so this thing if
at K is going to infinity and your alpha
is sort of remaining fixed it sort of
shrinking the simplex from its original
size to be away from the edges and for
large gates essentially zero volume
inside lake you're missing out all the
oh yeah you're right so in this result
I'm going to actually fix alpha but k is
also fixed if I fix alpha and then make
k go to infinity then this doesn't make
sense because that there are no
probability distribution satisfying this
so this was up with the Alpha assumption
there's some sensor eliminate the rare
symbols maybe somebody yeah just working
the regime with all those numbers is
looking for you so is there some
intuition for why you can't choose beta
equals zero yeah that's that's really
really great question I want if I had
more time I would have elaborated on
this result these assumptions are really
mild the only reason i put a beta
positive here is because the f
divergence may give me an infinite
penalty for at some points like for
example relative entropy so you are
right suppose suppose i want to use the
empirical estimator there are a wide
family of estimators that would work
here this ad beta is only the sub
exponential assumption is only so that
ad beta works remove the sub exponential
remove ad beta use the empirical
estimator except when you if
your empirical distribution assigned 0
near the end points then just say
uniform that estimator will give you
this performance yeah the lower bound I
described to you comes from evaluating
the base risk under the uniform prior
I'm not very sure about that I don't
know I don't know if the least favorable
prior is to choose uniform and if you
scale the alphabets in some way I I
suspect it's not
so the in the regret regime where you
some the loss of around there we have
the notion of both mix ability which
allows us to relate other losses to the
locals and you get a lot of reductions
that way I'm wondering if there is a
similar thing going on here because the
two losses you mentioned are exactly one
of the two famous mixable losses so
could that be the reason why these
things look so similar then we have
another result which I did not describe
you can consider the minimax expected
some of losses from times i equals 0
through n and we we can we can show that
as long as the pies are allowed to are
bounded away you the expected loss
behaves like k minus 1 f double prime
over 2 times log n i don't know how it's
related to the mix ability from but this
is easily extended to the case where the
loss is not at time n but at time
running from 0 to n what is the life
let's went out so artisan